what has Joseph Campbell taught you
about becoming an adult Joseph Campbell
taught me two key things about becoming
an adult that have really stayed with
me he said that the cave you fear to
enter often times holds the treasure
that you
seek that idea has stayed with me
because often times it is that story
I've been afraid to tell that has the
meaning I've been looking for the
expression that I
want so many times the cave that I have
feared to enter has been a cave
um of
laziness it's been a cave of commitment
to my
craft and and yet as I have
determined to enter that
cave I've seen magical things
appear when I say magical things I'm
referring to magical things within
myself see in essence that cave We Fear
to enter is always inside of us it's not
in the things we do it's that place
inside of ourselves that we're afraid to
go but this is what becoming an adult is
about being willing
to finally enter those deepest caves
inside ourselves that we've long been
afraid to
enter the other thing that Joseph
Campbell talked
about and this really was important to
my growth as a human being and my own
embracing of
adulthood it became a bumper sticker
many years later but he he used this
this phrase follow your bliss
it was advice that he used to give his
students at Sarah Lawrence College every
semester and certainly that idea has had
a number of critics that say well this
is just talking about uh you know
Hedonism and uh just whatever feels good
do it but that wasn't at all what he was
talking
about the sort of bliss that Joseph
Campbell was talking
about it's that which brings you
life that which makes life
full of wonder for you that which draws
your curiosity and causes you to think
Beyond
yourself later he he joked that he he
said I should have said follow your
blisters because so often uh it's it's a
painful Road following your bliss is not
always easy sometimes it can cost you
everything but it really is the only way
to fully come into your full self I mean
at the end of the day that's what all of
us are trying to do right we're trying
to become the fullest version of
ourselves that we
can Campbell said that he didn't so much
believe people were looking for the
meaning of life as much as they were the
rapturous experience of being
alive I don't believe any of us are
going to be on our deathbed talking
about a great text conversation we once
had I don't think any of us are going to
be on our deathbed talking about that
time we binge watched the final season
of Game of
Thrones I think we're going to be
talking about those moments that we
truly experienced what it was to live
not just to exist but to
live that is what adulthood has become
about from me not just existing not just
figuring out how to make it through the
day not just figuring out how to
navigate this complex world that we live
in but what does it mean to live a life
that's what I want how do stories help
us become adults there have been a
number of great thinkers who have looked
at how storytelling helps us become
adult
uh certainly You Know Carl Yung uh was
was instrumental in this but there was a
woman that worked with Carl Young named
Marie Louise Von fron and Von fron
specifically looked at fairy tales and
how fairy tales helped us become adults
and she went very deep into these ideas
that sat at the core of different fairy
tales and and one of the things that she
identified was that at the core of every
significant and meaning meaningful fairy
tale was a certain element of
danger and she was concerned as Society
kept moving forward that we had become
hellbent on removing that element of
danger from fairy tales because they
were so often given to
children and
sense this work became very influential
on uh others who begin to talk about the
importance of the element of danger in
stories in order to uh help us grow and
develop uh later Along Comes a man named
Bruno bleheim and he writes a book
called the uses of Enchantment and in
this book he also talks about how fairy
tales are very important form of
Storytelling in order to help us become
adults boheim says that when we remove
the
monster from the story that we share
with
children we rob that child from the
ability to learn how to confront the
monster he's most scared of that that
lives inside of him that monster that he
really gets to know over the course of
his
life I think Beyond just Fairy
Tales
stories they allow us the opportunity to
imagine a life beyond the here and now
they allow us to imagine a life that
could be for us in many ways I go to the
movies to see stories that are not just
inspirational but
aspirational I begin to question who I
could
be as I watched that story I think at
the at the center of every great
story is an invitation for the audience
to begin a conversation with
themselves great story tellers uh are
are not those who necessarily cause an
audience to sit and become completely
zeroed in on the
Storyteller but a great Storyteller
allows the audience to become zeroed in
on
thems this requires the death of your
own ego as a
Storyteller but here's the
thing people are not interested in how
great we could be as
storytellers they're not interested in
how great we are as a writer as a story
crafter people are interested in how
great they could
be and the stories that we create the
characters that we allow them to step
into if those characters if those
stories open up a place inside of them
that causes them to begin to imagine how
great they could
be then we've really done something is
those who create
stories we think of the quote kill the
boy Jon Snow winner is almost Upon Us
kill the boy and let the man be born
what does this quote stir up in you it's
essential that the younger person in
every one of us has to
die
however they must die so that they can
be
reborn the Mythic cycle is all about
death and
rebirth if the boy dies in me it's only
so a new boy can be born within
me and yes in some sense there's a
maturation process of becoming an adult
that I leave behind childish
things however there's also a discovery
of new things in life where I become a
child all over
again in some sense I am
re-entering my Boyhood I'm re-entering
childhood with every new relationship
that I develop with every new person
that I meet and with every new story
that I tell
one of the reasons that I think that's
important is because we want fresh eyes
we want to see the world
differently we want to tell a story in a
different way than we've ever told it
before so it becomes important that I'm
willing to let that boy die that the man
might
live but also so that that boy can be
reborn and a return of childlike Wonder
Rises up within me whenever I'm willing
to let that boy
die